augmenter ses rendements financiers et
faire peu de cas de son image c'est l'un
des traits de caractère du capitalisme
néolibéral en 2020 sanofi en est
l'exemple parfait
mi-mai le mastodonte pharmaceutique
français s'est attiré les foudres du
gouvernement et des européens en
promettant aux états unis les plus
grosses pré commandes d'un éventuel
vaccin contre le coc beat 19 après une
convocation à l'elysée de son directeur
général paul watson est une tempête
médiatico-politique
le groupe a préféré jouer l'apaisement
je veux être rassurant avec nos
concitoyens si on découvre un vaccin
efficace contre le coc u19
il sera accessible à tout le monde les
américains travaillent avec nous pour
mettre à disposition ce vaccin très vite
aux états unis nous travaillons avec
l'union européenne et plusieurs états
pour faire la même chose en europe
cette dernière phrase et sibylline
implicitement sanofi veut faire pression
sur l'europe et en plus des centaines de
millions d'euros que les états unis
devraient mettre sur la table
washington est aussi plus rapide à
faciliter des démarches réglementaires
pour permettre les recherches
c'est un modèle rôdé aux états unis mais
qui n'existe pas en europe
maintenant il ya une énorme volonté en
europe la prochaine étape sera
d'élaborer l'instrument pour garantir
que nous soyons capables d'assurer la
production en europe et dans le reste du
monde
cette course au vaccin pourrait bien
dégradé la réputation déjà mise à mal du
groupe pharmaceutique en france mais
cela at il encore de l'importance quand
les multinationales peuvent rivaliser
avec les états troisième plus grosse
capitalisation du cac 40 les revenus de
sanofi égale pratiquement le pib de la
tunisie
ou bien est de la bolivie plus de 36
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
en 2010 900 mille collaborateurs et des
sites de production dans 32 pays
différents et pourtant 1973 date de sa
création sa le fim est à ses débuts
qu'une start-up de 10 salariés filiale
du groupe pétrolier
aquitaine pour atteindre cette dimension
multinationales place à une politique
d'acquisitions tous azimuts a ajouté à
sa délocalisation l'an sociaux à tout va
et générosité avec ses actionnaires en
cinq ans on est passé de 47 sites à 33
sur le sol français mais ça ne les a pas
empêchés de toucher le crédit impôt
recherche
une réduction fiscale destinée à
stimuler la recherche sanofi compte
parmi les premiers bénéficiaires de
cette niche fiscale avec quelque 150
millions d'euros perçus annuellement à
l'époque un certain emmanuel macron
alors ministre de l'économie s'était
justifié de la sorte si on ne donnait
pas le crédit impôt recherche à cette
entreprise
ça fait plusieurs années qu'elle aurait
mis toute sa recherche et sans doute
même ses quartiers généraux hors de
france
efficace et visionnaire pour le coup le
patriotisme économique semble être à
géométrie variable dans la course aux
intérêts financiers cette nouvelle
polémique n'a rien de contraignant pour
sanofi bien au contraire ça ne fait que
monter les enchères
reste à savoir qui paiera le plus cher